I think that the women's magazines and a
lot of those quick tips for better sex I
think that they do people a disservice
sometimes because they become very
focused on their thinking they're
thinking oh ok i read that i should do
this and I am i doing it right there's a
certain amount of anxiety that comes
from thinking I don't know if I'm I'm
supposed to do it this way and I don't
know if he's responding and I don't know
if I am I doing this right and rather
than just being more led by just letting
it go where it takes you and losing
yourself in it instead of you know
trying this sort of menu of things you
read in a women's magazine there's a
certain amount of pressure I think also
among very young girls to do what's
expected of them and I don't know what
they're getting out of you know I just
don't think that that's the way to have
good sex so but that sort of in terms of
practical how to you know is that
there's the one study i found that was
the one sexual therapy technique that
seemed to be that worked well for women
and seemed to be pretty simple was like
mindfulness training is just all about
not spectator not watching yourself
being just being in the moment and not
being anxious about what's expected of
you or are you reacting right or is your
partner reacting right but that's no
easier said than done you know it's like
somebody telling you relax you know you
relax if you're relaxed